[Music]
hellboy is here and it's the total
disaster
there are a lot of factors behind the
failure of the superhero movie reboot
let's break down why it bombed at the
box office and see if we can nail down
just what exactly went so wrong
with hellboy 2019 the critics have
spoken and they weren't pleased
but most damning for the hellboy
franchise's future prospects it's the
fact that this version of big red didn't
make any money at all
according to box office mojo the opening
weekend for hellboy brought in
considerably less than even studio
lionsgate's lowest expectations
while the studio hoped for at least a 17
million dollar take to start things off
for the movie theatrical run hellboy
instead brought back
only 12 million dollars from more than 3
300 theaters
earning a third place at the domestic
box office during its debut
all that against the budget that's been
reported to be at least 50 million
dollars
in other words it looks like everyone
who backed this project is about to lose
their money
clearly the world wasn't on fire with
anticipation for a new rebooted hellboy
movie but not many predicted it would
turn out this bad
as reviews rolled in over the movie's
opening weekend hillboy's rotten
tomatoes score hovered near the single
digits
eventually reaching a 15 rating with
roughly 150 reviews
naturally the reactions are full of
punny alley-oops the movie is like a
personal hell or at least the tenth
circle of one
it's a hell of a headache and a hellish
experience it both came from and can go
to
you get it the point is people hated
this movie one of the more understated
disses came from the associated press
review which read
so underwhelming was this film that a
recent screening in new york
only sparked polite applause after it
was finally over and that was a red
carpet premiere with all the cast in
attendance
i'm are you serious one of the biggest
problems a new hellboy failed to
overcome is many fans continuing
allegiance to the original two movies
directed by guillermo del toro
long before this new version of the
franchise was being worked on del toro
and original hellboy ron pearlman were
ready and willing to step up for a third
act
but over the course of the next decade
hopes for that reunion ever happening
slowly faded with producers steering the
property toward a reboot instead
what's my flaw what makes the reboot
treatment really sting is less that it
happened and more that pullman and del
toro never stopped trying to make their
vision of a third movie a reality
poem related to collider in 2018 i spent
a long
long time really poking and prodding the
bird to get the third one made
and i fell short the results of this
gamble on a new direction were ugly and
unprofitable
with the new hellboy grossing
considerably less in its opening weekend
and either of its predecessors the
franchise's previous movie 2009's the
golden army
went on to a worldwide gross of 160
million dollars
good luck reaching those highs again
after a stinker like this
if passing over del toro and perlman was
the hellboy reboot's original sin
it didn't necessarily damn the entire
movie with a unified vision and a great
team effort
things still could have turned out okay
but apparently not everyone making the
movie was on the same team
according to a scintillating writer by
the rap the production of hellboy 29 was
plagued by infighting
disagreements and even a controversial
firing the specifics of the gossip are
frequently delicious
allegedly a producer of the movie
frequently stepped on the director's
toes leaving the actors with
contradictory instructions regarding how
to play scenes
also allegedly star david harbour was a
multiple times frustrated enough to
simply walk off the set during shooting
the report also claims that the script
was being rewritten during production
which might help to explain the story's
overall disjointed feel
it's easy to see how an atmosphere like
this could lead to the creation of a
subpar
movie but whatever the reasons behind it
being lousy are we're sure there are
plenty of people who might just want
their money back
comic book series can exist for years or
even decades before getting a shot on
the big screen
often spalling out whole encyclopedias
worth of confusing law in the process
as a result it's extremely easy for
adaptations to fall into the trap of
becoming over-complicated messes with
too much story
too many characters or simply too much
weird crap going on for a general
audience to get on board with
according to many reviews hellboy's
biggest problem is how over-complicated
and confusing its plot developments can
be
with important characters remaining
strangely two-dimensional or the movie
waste time with cameos and comic book
references
well parts of the movie that may delight
readers of the comic books with
satisfaction of the oh i recognize that
variety they might come off to casual
fans as weird momentum killing
digressions
even people who know the comics might
not be able to get around the movie's
breathless pace and stunning density in
trying to include so much the movie
succeeds in conveying very little
and it's a superhero movie all it needed
to be was good guys versus bad guys how
the heck do you go about screwing that
up
out of the people who did see hellboy
enough walked away agitated enough to
saddle it with an abysmal
c rating at cinema score while a c may
come off as average
it's actually quite lousy for a movie
like this a cinema score rating reflects
the results of theatrical exit polls
with regular people leaving opening
night screenings basically being asked
if they liked what they saw and got what
they paid for
movies for general audiences tend to
easily get a's and b's
while lower ratings are often more
reserved for horror movies which tend to
be unconventional by nature
while hellboy certainly has its horror
elements it's more aspiring to be the
same kind of beast as deadpool
playing as a crowd-pleasing
four-quadrant blockbuster with some
blood and guts and naughty words
that's what the movie sold itself as but
a sea cinema score suggests that people
did not get what they wanted out of
hellboy whether it was too gory too
confusing or just too weird
it also suggests that people won't be
running to tell their friends to go see
it either
meaning any hopes of the movie picking
up speed in the weeks after its debut
are pretty low especially with the
avengers right around the corner
at that point it's curtains for all
hellboy in hindsight they probably
should have just let guimo finish as
trilogy
it couldn't have turned out much worse
than this check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one